[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar take action against viral hcv
by leveraging screening programs and hcv
antigens
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by abbott diagnostics to learn more
visit core laboratory dot abbott
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
mia biandi assistant professor school of
nursing york university
dr biandi you may now begin your
presentation
hello all thank you so much to the
organizers and abbott for bringing this
webinar together today um really an
honor to be here and as mentioned uh i'm
an assistant professor at york
university and also a researcher at the
viral hepatitis care network out of
toronto general hospital in toronto
so just wanted to start off by saying
thank you for joining us either live
today or later on of course today is
world by world hepatitis day and today
we're going to be specifically speaking
about hepatitis c
so i'll just go through quickly my
disclosures so these are some of the
folks that i
consult for or
receive fees for but also just wanted to
mention that a lot of the consulting
that i do actually goes back into my
research program which does focus on
viral hepatitis
so just by way of introduction i'm sure
many of you here know that um the who
sign and many countries have signed on
towards the elimination of viral
hepatitis by 2030 and that's obviously
incredibly important but what i want to
just mention is in addition to the
morbidity and mortality caused by
chronic hepatitis b and c
um hepatitis b and c is also increasing
in morbidity and mortality over time so
unlike the other three major infectious
diseases that we think about globally
malaria hiv and tuberculosis which are
all going down viral hepatitis is
actually increasing and it's becoming a
leading cause of liver cancer certainly
in resource-rich settings as well as in
other settings where there might may be
an under diagnosis
and
one of the reasons why
i'm sorry um and just in terms of our
why we are coming here today so really
to focus on what we can do
both um community wise regionally
locally as well as globally in terms of
eliminating viral hepatitis and of
course you're probably familiar of our
tagline here of hep can't wait
so in terms of the reasons why we can
actually achieve viral elimination so
although the who called for this
elimination by 2030 there was actually
some particular reasons why it's
possible and so some of these things
include uh the shift of thinking about
hepatitis c virus as a chronic disease
to now a curable
treatable and curable disease and that
shift has really come for both providers
and patients we also have huge
advancements in diagnostics so this
includes things like community-based
point-of-care testing point-of-care
testing that
could be done by a provider but could
also be done by a peer
or a health ambassador or community
health worker
the thought around it reflex testing
which i'm going to spend a good amount
of time on in just a few minutes
using dried blood spots to collect
samples this could be serology samples
or nucleic acid based samples and then
thinking really outside of the box you
know a lot of the world does
self-testing certainly in the context of
covet as we've seen but for a lot of
other infectious diseases so thinking
about things like self-testing
and finally
viral hepatitis elimination in
particular hepatitis c
is achievable because we have excellent
treatment so we have pan-genotypic
treatment that means it works across all
genotypes and we have very high cure
rates in unquote all populations and
what i mean by all populations is people
who may not typically have had access to
interference-based therapy so people who
use drugs people who have severe and
persistent mental health challenges and
the cure rates in these populations
are equal um
across every group and so there's no
reason to withhold treatment for any
particular population
just because we're going to be talking a
lot about
diagnostics today i want to spend a
little bit of time on hcv virology so as
you're aware this is a single stranded
positive sense rna genome it's an
enveloped virus i do have the family and
the genus lift it listed there and i
just want to draw your attention to the
figure there of the viral particle
um so thinking about you know what we're
actually looking at in terms of
diagnostics so we could be looking at
the antibody response we could be
looking at
trying to detect viral nucleic acid so
this would be viral rna by pcr and then
just to point out the core protein there
uh in blue because we are going to be
speaking a little bit about some
alternative diagnostic pathways that
could involve
core antigen
in order to really understand what we're
doing in terms of diagnostics it is a
bit helpful to look at the natural
history of hepatitis c and so when we
think about an acute infection we have
early infection with a spike in viral
nucleic acid so a spike in hcv rna and
in that first phase there is blips so it
goes up and down and up and down and the
same is often mirrored in by the alt
response
um 50 to 20 to 50 percent of these folks
actually do go on to clear the virus so
they clear acute infection
and
many of them go on to become chronic and
when they are chronic have
leveling of it out of that viral rna as
well as alt
at the three week mark this is when we
recommend people be tested for hep c
antibodies or sorry three month mark
after exposure so 12 weeks after
exposure is when we first look for
antibodies after a new infection
um and the time frame for acute
infection although it can go beyond six
months and some people do clear their
chronic infection after six months we
typically say people are chronically
infected after that six month mark and
why that's at least relevant in here in
canada is because currently um we only
treat chronic infections as per health
canada labeling
but there could certainly be value to
treating people when they are in the
acute stage
so there's been a major shift in the
treatment of viral hepatitis and i'm
sure many of those who are watching this
today
were treaters or providers in the
context of the interferon era and so in
the interferon era
very small numbers of people were being
treated and they really had to have
advanced liver disease in order to be
eligible because treatment was so
intensive
um it usually required a specialists so
hepatologists
infectious disease providers who had a
lot of experience in this area and at
least in canada our governments had a
very extensive paperwork in terms of
getting them medications covered
it required a huge team so a
multi-disciplinary team
that included social work and nurses and
physicians there was frequent monitoring
on treatment and decisions were actually
made in terms of on treatment monitoring
from a response guided therapy approach
today
there has been such a huge shift we have
excellent excellent direct acting
antivirals which are all oral
and that's been a really big part of the
shift
but because they're all oral and because
they're so well tolerated with very high
cure rates we've been able to treat very
large numbers of people so early on when
we had direct acting antivirals
there were many people who were awaiting
this therapy and now what we're doing
we've treated most of those people and
now what we're doing is really working
on the case finding aspect so people can
are covered at least in canada if they
don't have liver disease
anyone who is a prescriber
in our regions can prescribe hepatitis c
treatment so it's no longer restricted
to
specialists and nor does it need to be
there are very simple medications and
it's easy for patients and clients to
understand we have lots of practices
where there's just a single provider
doing the care often in collaboration
with caseworkers as opposed to other
healthcare providers we really don't
need to change anything while people are
on treatment so little or no on
treatment monitoring and the medications
are extremely well tolerated and so for
those reasons of advancements in
diagnostics and advancements in
treatment we really can think about
global hepatitis elimination
this is a really nice study that came
out this year early 2022 and it looks at
the global burden of hepatitis c but
specifically from the perspective of
people who are actively viremic and so
just drawing your attention to some of
the lower prevalence countries versus
some of the higher prevalence countries
and this same study actually did a bit
of a trajectory between 2015 and 2020 so
right before the covet 19 pandemic to
look at the impact of direct acting
antivirals on the prevalence of
viremic infections so people who are
actively infected with hepatitis c
and what is actually i think a bit
surprising to most people who see these
data is that in
many many countries the impact of direct
acting antivirals has not affected the
prevalence as much as we thought it
would so if a country had a prevalence
of you know 1.9 positivity for viremic
infections it's now 1.8 and i'm going to
go into some of the reasons why in a few
moments
um in terms of people accessing
testing screening linkage to care and
treatment there are still sort of three
pillars that are really impacting our
ability to eliminate viral hepatitis so
there are some pieces at the individual
level at the patient level and some of
these things include competing
priorities so
being treated for hepatitis c might not
be people's number one priority it might
not even be people's number one health
priority
um we talk about geographical and
structural barriers so looking at stigma
in health care settings the ability to
actually attend appointments
needing to sit for
you know half an hour to many hours in a
specialty office and all of these things
can really impact people's motivation to
be treated not to mention the fact that
most people are asymptomatic and so
really are not feeling the impacts
presently of their viral illness
there is still quite a lot of stigma
amongst providers so even shifting the
way providers think about people who are
actively injecting drugs
is a huge task that we have to
work towards in the context of the
opioid epidemic which has affected so
many countries globally
this further perpetuates the stigma
because people might have been
re-infected
um
and providers might make a judgment
about those sorts of things and then
there are many systems barriers so
if it takes many steps to
get screened and then linked to care and
then treated um this access to services
access to what we call
low barrier models of care are not
present throughout our system and
therefore people still have wait times
um they're still
having to potentially travel long
distances to seek care and in the
context of
telehealth or virtual care in the
pandemic this has made an impact
but those people then really need to
have bones and technology in terms of
accessing that virtual care
so in canada we have set out
the blueprint to inform hepatitis c
elimination efforts and there's been
this identification of six priority
populations and so these populations
include people who use drugs or inject
drugs
indigenous communities those who are
criminalized or incarcerated gained
bisexual men have sex with men
immigrants and newcomers and older
adults and by older adults so we have a
mandate to do birth cohort screening and
so in canada they've decided that that's
1945 to 1975 but of course in other
places in the world
there's an adoption of screening all
adults once
as well as more aggressive strategies if
there's outbreaks including among gay
and bisexual men and things like that
and so these are the six priority
populations that were set out by in 2019
but
um of course there are going to be new
emerging priority populations so we're
seeing that in line with the opioid
epidemic that there are many more new
infections
in young people
infections in young women and then
there's of course a lot of overlap in
these what we're calling priority
populations so among people who use
drugs who may also be newcomers to
canada or
and that intersectionality that often
exists in so much of this work and you
might be um hearing or interested around
that
screening and pregnancy aspect which is
i think is becoming
a real thought-provoking discussion
around screening and treatment in
pregnancy
um and although we can't intervene in
pregnancy there is this opportunity to
link people to care while they are
pregnant because it might be the one
time where people are seeking care
the impact of covid19 on hepatitis c
testing of course has been tremendous
um
it's been quite significant and these
are just two studies from two different
provinces in in canada where i am
um so one in british
in ontario to really show that
exactly in line with the shutdowns of
the provinces
there were huge drops in testings of
screening and diagnosis for hepatitis c
and although
they came up
throughout the rest of the pandemic so
in our ontario study we looked at the
first wave the second wave and the third
wave they had not reached pre-pandemic
levels and what i would suspect is with
the wide adoption of virtual care and
getting a bit back to normal
um certainly we are probably closer to
where we were pre-pandemic but we have
definitely not fully rebounded and in
terms of treatments treatments were
actually going down even prior to the
pandemic and so the pandemic just
further exacerbated an existing problem
i really like to talk about the care
continuum when it comes to looking at
the pre-treat
cascade of care for hepatitis c and it's
really just to hone in on the fact that
there are so many steps for people from
screening
to cure and we can really spend a lot of
time thinking about how we can reduce
the number of steps so i think in a
perfect model in a non-serotic
population
treatment can be initiated certainly in
two visits but what often happens is
something more similar to what you're
seeing here where an individual is
seeing a provider they need to go get
labs they need to speak or see the
provider again maybe they need more labs
or imaging or a fiber scan and then each
one of these steps that ltfu there's the
potential for loss to follow-up and if
this individual at the top that they're
seeing as a provider is also a
non-specialist and at any time is
uncomfortable with the care they might
think about doing a referral which is
completely appropriate however every
time we refer we also
lost a follow-up and a barrier to
treatment and care and even though we've
done a lot i think as people who work in
outreach settings to really decrease the
number of steps like using point of care
antibody testing drawing blood on spot
site or using dried blood spot
collection
covid impacted a lot of these systems
that we were creating
to decrease the barriers to care so
perhaps we weren't able to go in to see
people where they were being housed or
where they were going and dropping in
for food and so we lost this access
point where people were already seeking
another service and our ability to
screen and treat for hepatitis c
this is a really nice study that i just
wanted to bring your attention to it was
a global survey among hepatitis
providers and program managers to look
at what was the impact to the services
delivered
for hepatitis c during
being pandemic and a lot of the concerns
were actually of course at the staff
level so
loss of staff limited staff
fear and anxiety among patients
lack of ppe and supply shortages but i
think we can all appreciate
that out of this pandemic there's
actually been some streamlined pathways
to care so perhaps people that used to
feel that they needed to to do a fiber
scan in order to treat someone for
hepatitis c realize that they don't and
they wouldn't be able to in the context
of the pandemic
there might have been more emphasis on
really thinking about our testing
platforms because there was such high
volume testing for covid so can we
replicate that for hepatitis c as well
um really speaking to colleagues in
terms of the referral networks
and really thinking about you know how
can we improve
training how can we have people who are
doing covid testing
also doing have c testing and really
co-localize that care
in terms of some of the models that i
work in so we kind of think about this
as our our hepatitis c pathway to care
and you know we could have referrals
from uh outpatient clinics or emergency
rooms or primary health care or sexual
health
um but most of our testing
and diagnosis comes from street outreach
from screening people where they're at
in other types of services like opioid
agonist therapy or trauma-informed drug
rehabilitation and so we really see
ourselves as sort of that central access
point um but what i wanted to mention
was our program is only really
successful because it's entirely
self-referral so it's entirely just to
call the provider
very low barrier they can often speak
directly to the provider without having
to
leave a voicemail or wait wait on the
phone and this has been extremely
helpful
we also are real at are really
advocating for
moving forward on other types of
communication so
certainly in the context of virtual care
and the pandemic many clinics adopted
video based care phone-based care and
we've always been advocating that we
need to do more text-based care and
email-based care because it might be the
only way that we can reach individuals
in terms of other types of settings like
the correction system
certainly we've had challenges in canada
around treating in correctional base
systems but there's also a thought
around universal screening in that types
of environments and then of course
universal screening and other
environments where there might be a high
prevalence
um traditional in-person care is still
sometimes desired depending on the
population but we found that essentially
we need to offer a menu of approaches
and then determine how the person wants
to move from that point onwards
so although all that sounds a little bit
complicated our simplified model for hcv
care really only has three components
and this is where we've sort of been the
most successful
so we need an opportunity to actually
provide care so what does that look like
what does that mean well that could be
again in an opioid agonist therapy
clinic that could be in drug rehab that
could be in medical detox that could be
while people are incarcerated um so what
is that opportunity
that we're going to be able to provide
care provide screening provide treatment
we've also found that a major aspect to
all of our programs is engaging peers or
people with lived experience and i use
the word peer and sort of a broad
perspective but
it could include people who have
experience with hepatitis c but it could
also just be people who have a shared
journey so if we're doing a program with
women who have experienced violence
that our peers might have had some of
that shared journey
the same would be true of people who use
drugs or people have been incarcerated
where we know these models are really
the best way to reach individuals and
then we need some sort of clinician
involvement so that could be nurses that
could be physicians that could be social
workers
but just having that aspect of clinician
involvement and in our programs which
are extremely low barrier
the clinicians are really in the
background actually so the peers are
usually leading the programs and the
clinicians are doing some of the
oversight um but most of the care is
really driven by that pure lead model
which is at least where we think we need
to be to eliminate viral hepatitis
but this whole pathway starts with a
testing algorithm so just as a reminder
our first test our screening test for
hepatitis c is an antibody test so
anti-hcv and if individuals are positive
of course that means that they've been
exposed and just as a reminder that
they're going to be antibody positive
for life
if they are negative we usually
recommend screaming every six months
if they have ongoing risk factors
now i'm don't have anything here about
reflex testing and i will get to them in
a moment but
um the next step after antibody
positivity is going to be confirming
active infection and that can be done in
multiple ways and so i want to start to
introduce you to some other ways or we
might consider confirming active
infection if they're actively infected
it's helpful to get a genotype sometimes
you don't need it but you might want it
in a serratic population
and one of the most interesting things
about viral hepatitis elimination i
think is that you know really in order
to achieve it we're gonna have to
address this undiagnosed fraction so in
a place like canada we propose that our
undiagnosed fraction is somewhere around
44 percent but based on the literature
in a lot of countries the undiagnosed
fraction could be up to 95 percent
and then in countries where there is
some robust screening and treatment is
readily accessible
we still are struggling towards that
elimination goal because
new infections are actually outpacing
the number of individuals who are cured
when we think about testing we really
need to just sort of break down the
testing modalities and so just as a
reminder when i'm speaking about these
different testing modalities so
hepatitis c antibody antibody positivity
it's the body's way of showing that they
it's seen the virus before
and
um in the context of some viruses it
could be exposure or infection and in
hep c we wouldn't know until we went to
the next step
hepatitis c core antigen so an antigen
just as a reminder is a protein it's a
piece of the virus if you can detect the
antigen that means there's virus there
and then nucleic acid-based testing
which even the public has become
extremely comfortable with
pcr testing for covid and so that's
exactly what we mean we're looking at
pcr testing nucleic acid-based testing
for viral rna so hepatitis c rna which
is the presence of the virus and again
is that active infection
and in some regions that test could just
be a positive or negative or in some
regions that test would be quantitative
and would be known as a viral load a
quantitative measurement which can
either be in international units so i
use per ml or copies per ml to give the
viral load and the only thing that i'll
leave with on just speaking about the
viral load is that we're still
addressing a lot of the myths
in the community around the relevance of
viral load so there are still many
providers that would think that
hepatitis c is similar to hepatitis b
where the viral load could affect
progression to advance liver disease and
that people with low viral loads may not
need to be treated and of course that's
not correct and we should treat anyone
who is positive for the virus
so i'm going to use this term moving
forward reflex testing and it's really
to say that you know reflex testing
really needs to be thought of as the
gold standard and luckily a lot of major
labs globally have moved to reflex
testing
i'm going to speak a little bit about
the canadian landscape in a moment but
reflex testing means that the sample
that's been tested for hep c antibody is
the same sample that's used for the test
of active infection
and that has extreme important
importance especially in a difficult to
reach population so when we think about
our testing toolkit you know we might
consider starting off with a traditional
beanie puncture based antibody test this
is helpful
to be used when
the costs of point of care testing are
too great and there is that ability to
send to a high volume testing lab
but that sample really needs to be
reflexed to either a core antigen test
or pcr based testing or looking for
viral nucleic acid and i'll sort of
discuss why you might consider one or
over the other in various environments
but this quote-unquote reflex testing
eliminates the need for two
tests and i'll just speak about why
that's so important in a moment
so i'm sure that we don't need a crash
course in
pcr again with covid we've spoken so
much about it but i do want to talk a
little bit about looking at that
antigen-based testing so hcv core
antigen testing
is commercially available
it's a
chemiluminescent microparticle
immunoassay
and it looks at active infection so it's
just as i mentioned before the presence
of antigen means active infection
the limit of detection is three f moles
per liter
and in terms of the studies around
sensitivity i just want to preface this
by saying there has been a lot of
investigation into this assay and the
sensitivity is around 94 percent
although
there's really a viral load cut off so
when the viral load is higher
than
300 3 000 i use per ml
the sensitivity approaches 100
and the specificity so the ability
in order to rule out um false positives
actually approaches 100
this is some some work that we've done
that's on the right hand side of the
screen there looking at the diagnosis
stage and then the stage for cure which
is svr or sustained virological response
and just wanting to point out that in
terms of the correlation between core
antigen and hcv rna they are extremely
well correlated and so that's sort of
the science behind you know whether or
not we should be using this test but in
terms of the practical reasons why we
should be using it it really keeps the
reflex testing in the serology-based
pathway so if we're concerned about as
laboratorians or clinicians
about rna degradation and how that might
affect sensitivity
by using core antigen that really keeps
it in the same serological pathway and
this is sometimes helpful in high volume
labs that have a sort of a serology
section and then which is separate from
the nucleic acid-based testing section
it's also less expensive so i won't
speak extensively about the
cost-effective analysis but our group
has done a bit of work just around the
costing and it's not just less expensive
for the lab because the reagents are
less per test but it's also much less
expensive to the system so when we did
some modeling at least in in where we
are in canada it's five times less
expensive to use an antigen test over
nucleic acid testing and in a lot of
environments especially in our currently
stretched health care system this is
really something to consider
so why should reflex testing actually be
the goal why did i say that at the
beginning well depending on the
population and the study
the number of individuals that are lost
to follow-up between antibody testing
and determining if they have active
infection is anywhere 30 to 50 percent
so 30 to 50 percent never move on to
that second step in the cascade of even
knowing if they're positive or not
and i think it's very interesting from
the patient perspective and
sort of the diagnosis that they've been
given because i have had so many
patients that
certainly believed they were hepatitis c
positive and they were but all we
actually knew was that they were
positive by antibody testing and so that
aspect of confirming the active
confection is often lost among these
difficult to reach populations
we should really be considering
which modality is the right test
for the right environment and so when we
think about you know approaches to
diagnostic algorithms
there are a few things that we really
want to consider
so one would be what is the prevalence
in that region where we're going to be
doing the testing
what is the testing setting and what i
mean by that is are we doing it out of
the trunk of a car are we doing it in a
mobile van is it in a shelter isn't it
in a traditional clinic
um what sort of options do we have
available can we do point of care
antibody and dry blood spot or is this
all going to be going to high throughput
labs so really thinking about what is
the mixing and matching that we can do
between
antibody testing nucleic acid based
testing and core antigen testing
to really maximize that testing
algorithm and then looking at costs and
what i want to say here is in the
context of nucleic acid based testing in
certain parts of the world
the cost of the test
can actually be more than the cost of
the treatment and so you can imagine
that in some regions of the world it's
even more cost effective to treat just
based on a positive antibody alone
without even knowing if an individual is
actively infected but using core antigen
can actually give us that information
around active infection as well as
decrease the cost
so we've been looking at this in canada
and really trying to look at the
differences from region to region or
province to province around what
different provinces are doing in terms
of their testing algorithm and
unfortunately we still do not have all
provinces doing reflex testing so three
provinces are not doing reflex testing
in terms of nucleic acid-based testing
but one of those provinces has
incorporated hep c core antigen testing
to be that reflex test and actually keep
it in that serological pathway as i
mentioned we still have two provinces
and i'm living in one of them in ontario
canada where
there is not yet any type of reflex
testing and we absolutely see this drop
off of 30 percent of individuals who
never get confirmation of active
infection
two provinces in canada uh very stupidly
incorporate core antigen testing into
their algorithm and i'm going to go to
show you what those look like
so those are in the provinces of
saskatchewan and manitoba and what
they've decided to do
is for anyone who is antibody positive
they actually evaluate the cutoff for
antibody testing to decide if they're
going to report it as negative
or if they're going to progress on to
requesting another sample or in manitoba
using the same sample for hcv rna
testing and this allows a basically a
triage effect in terms of the testing
algorithm which is cost saving
and just in terms of thinking about you
know what are the right tests for the
right populations and the right reasons
i wanted to think help you consider
three ways that we could maximize our
testing algorithms
so the first scenario would be
a person is tested for antibody
if they are negative no further testing
is required as i mentioned you might
consider retesting them in six months if
they have active risk factors
but after an antibody positive test
moving on to
a core antigen test and so if core
positive
we know positive they're actively
infected
linked to care or you know maybe they've
been treated and we're actually
evaluating for viral relapse or
treatment failure
if they're core negative we could
consider doing nucleic acid testing on
all samples which is a bit different
than what i mentioned around using the
antibody cut off
and again if positive linked to care or
evaluate for relapse and if negative you
know future testing is clinically
indicated and what i mean by that is
if there is a high degree of suspicion
that
they have a low viral load
and you might be missing them with the
core test
and their hcv rna undetectable
you may want to consider retesting them
in three to six months
so some of the advantages is that by
using the core testing after antibody
testing we eliminate this initial
concern around um rna degradation and
this has come up often it comes up often
with laboratorians around how long can
the sample sit in the fridge before
it'll impact the viral load and will
that make a sample go from positive to
negative
um
when we think about diagnosing chronic
infection we actually should be
considering you know what tests are the
right tests for each individual stage in
the cascade so there's the diagnosis
stage there's also the test of cure
stage or the svr stage and we could be
using core antigen for both the first
test as well as the test to confirm
chronic infection so six months later
and then i just really want to point out
as i mentioned in this algorithm that
when somebody is core negative but rna
positive that person likely has a viral
load that's very low
so anywhere less than 3 000 ius per ml
and
interestingly when many studies came out
about the use of coriantogen testing the
who looked at it from a global
perspective of how many individuals
might be missed in this scenario and
only about five percent of individuals
have a viral load that low and the
really important part is is that most
people will not have a viral load that
low ongoing
in terms of a different type of scenario
so in this scenario we actually have no
nucleic acid-based testing at all so
thinking about after an antibody
positive test progressing on to a core
antigen test if they're positive linked
to care or evaluate for treatment
failure or viral relapse
are they core antigen negative and then
not having the option of nucleic
acid-based testing which i'll go into
some of the reasons in a moment
but just thinking about okay they're
negative do i have a high degree of
suspicion if yes
retest by core antigen in three to six
months
some advantages here again eliminates
this concern of rna degradation and
where this is particularly important are
in regions where samples will not be
immediately tested perhaps there's a
distance which they need to be shipped
perhaps those storage conditions are not
ideal so it could be like us in canada
where it's shipped for a couple of days
from very cold temperatures or in other
regions of the world where the
temperatures are extremely warm
also just to speak to the cost again so
why is there no nucleic acid-based
testing in this algorithm at all well
again it speaks to the fact that in some
regions of the world nucleic acid-based
testing is so expensive
more expensive than the cost of the
treatment that it's simply not doable to
incorporate this modality into the
testing algorithm
the third scenario which i think is a
pretty exciting scenario and i think
probably where we need to move to is to
get rid of antibody testing among
populations and in regions where the
prevalence is extremely high so by that
i mean anywhere from 10
to 50 percent which we might see in a
population of people who use drugs or a
population of people with severe and
persistent mental health issues
and so actually screening with core
antigen so can you imagine just a single
test
to look for active infection and so yes
we will not know about their exposure
status but we will know if they're
actively infected which is truly what we
really care about so this could be used
in places like opioid agonist therapy
clinics or supervised injection sites
overdose prevention sites or in parts of
the world like canada we actually have
safe supply programs so this is when we
prescribe opioids so that they're not
tainted
and these folks might have a higher
prevalence of pepsi so knowing
immediately if they are actively
infected
could decrease the time from diagnosis
to
treatment
another thought would be to use core
antigen testing for
people that we already know are antibody
positive so looking back at our
databases if we have them or we already
know their status and maybe they've even
been treated and so we could look at
this core antigen test from a test of
cure perspective or using for svr
or looking for reinfection so in that
population that are known antibody
positive because they've been diagnosed
they've maybe been treated and you have
a high degree of suspicion that they
failed therapy or they're potentially
reinfected which we're seeing so much
coming out of the pandemic
using core antigen as that re-screen for
active infection
and again just to speak to the fact that
the costs might be so high for looking
for reinfection using nucleic acid based
testing or pcr based testing that this
is a time when we really want to
consider using core antigen testing
i just like to end with a couple of
conclusion slides so in terms of our
model we really look at this that we
need to test and treat people where they
are at in life and location so our work
really incorporates every single aspect
of social services
um looking at things like training
primary care providers making them aware
of different modalities for testing
diagnosis and treatment and in primary
care thinking about things like you know
testing every new patient
using it in the context of i'm already
ordering blood work so i'll order hep c
screening thinking about people that do
have risk factors
and thinking about people that have
other types of liver disease like
alcohol or fatty liver
in terms of a mental health or
corrections scenario so certainly using
core antigen testing in a region that
have a high prevalence or a location
that would have a high prevalence like
corrections
could certainly make sense
some inpatient mental health studies
have shown that prevalence can be as
high as 15 percent and that it would
hold true in community mental health
settings and of course much higher in
addiction settings
in terms of outreach so this is what i
mean by meeting people where they're at
and life and location hep c might not be
on their radar whatsoever
but if we can work with them in terms of
where they're at in shelter in drop-ins
and pharmacies we've sent seen the
incredible impact in canada of engaging
our pharmacy colleagues to do screening
and testing for covin and we should be
able to do the same for hepatitis c
thinking about doing home visits gosh
you know driving to someone's house and
having them tested in the comfort of
their own home looking at newcomer and
immigrant social services sites where we
can work with folks and then working
with people who have experienced
violence who are very unlikely to seek
care and might have been stigmatized in
the past
and then finally thinking about your
tertiary care settings not to leave
tertiary care settings out but to think
about them in a different way so in the
past we thought about tertiary care
settings as the place where we would
diagnose and treat hepatitis c and now
we can be looking at tertiary care
settings as places where we can actually
screen universally for hep c so thinking
about emergency rooms and then other
populations which will have overlapping
health complications um from hepatitis c
like our diabetic population who most
often has fatty liver disease that
obviously treating them for hepatitis c
would be advantageous looking at those
in renal failure in cardiology clinics
and then you know even thinking about
out of the box thinking like obstetrical
practices geriatric practices and
pediatric practices
of course in the context of testing it's
not a one-size-fits-all approach we
really need to evaluate these individual
scenarios these individual settings for
what's the best algorithm for each of
these populations because that's really
what this is all about this is about
meeting the individuals and working with
them in the way that they want to
receive care
i'll just end off with a couple of sort
of take-home conclusions around that
screening and diagnosis
aspect of the talk so one thought would
be around optimizing testing and how can
we do that well we really should think
hard about incorporating core androgen
into our testing algorithms so moving
from
antibody positivity to
reflex testing this helps us keep this
in this serological wheelhouse
when hep c rna testing is not readily
available when samples need to be
shipped or when it's too expensive
thinking about core antigen testing as a
first screening tool i really do hope we
get there i hope we can wrap our heads
around using core antigen or other
measures of active infection for an
initial test because in a population
that has a very high prevalence of
antibody positivity it might not be that
helpful to be screening these folks by
antibody testing and then in terms of
repeat testing so we could be using
coriantogen
to establish chronicity as well as
looking at
test of cure and then testing for
reinfection
i did present some work from our group
today and so i just wanted to
acknowledge many of the authors that
were involved in the work that i
presented
and again just to thank abbott and lab
roots for hosting this webinar today
it's been an absolute privilege to be
here with you and i'd be happy to take
any questions
thank you dr biandi for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
is hepatitis spread through saliva
yeah so um as far as we know it is not
um one thing to think about in terms of
oral hygiene
is that if people had gingivitis or
bleeding gums that it could be
transmitted by things like sharing a
toothbrush because there might be small
amounts of blood on the toothbrush and
then the other individual uses the
toothbrush
that being said
uh we can
there are some testing modalities and um
some investigation into saliva based or
bugle swab testing for hep c but not
transmission thanks good question
thank you
next question
who would be missed by core antigen
testing
yeah so i think it's a really important
question because when we talk about
sensitivity
um i think as laboratorians you know we
really want perfect sensitivity and we
find it challenging to not accept that
close to 100 sensitivity and of course
the data i presented here today was
based on a few different studies that
had an average sensitivity of about 94
percent
but
when tests i'm sorry when samples that
had higher viral loads
beyond that threshold of one thousand to
three thousand ius per ml
sensitivity approached
um 100
and so this is extremely important to
think about because in the context of
all of those individuals with chronic
hepatitis c
as i mentioned only about five percent
are going to be below that cut off so
certainly we might miss some acute
infections but if our goal is to treat
those chronically infected we will not
miss that same six percent as we think
we will because most people with chronic
infection will have a viral load above
that core antigen cut off
thank you next question
what role does testing play in reaching
hcv elimination by 2030 especially
considering the need to recover from
covid19
yeah so i mean what we showed in ontario
is that testing went down by somewhere
around 35
in the context of covid19
additionally covid19 has put tremendous
pressure on our health care system
and on the diagnostic system that we had
in place so there might be some
advantages that we can see from that so
we've created really good lab-based
testing pathways to optimize screening
for covid19 and so one thought in terms
of recovery would be to leverage some of
these pathways including new equipment
and
use those same testing pathways and
those same pieces of equipment for
increasing our ability to screen and
test for hep c i think in an outrage
outreach setting if you take nothing
else home from my talk today it's that
reflex testing is essential
thank you
next question
if
parents are infected
how do you prevent
their baby or their child
from having hepatitis
yeah so unlike hepatitis b
household transmission
is not as common
and so outside of those pieces that i
mentioned about toothbrushes
sharing nail clippers sharing tweezers
sharing things that could have
small amounts of blood
household transmission
is not common
however
when we think about parents and we think
about pregnancy
vertical transmission
is actually five percent and in the
context of an hiv hepatitis c
co-infection can approach
11 to 12 percent
we just published a study to show that
there's a potential that viral load
could actually
increase the potential for vertical
transmission so in the context of
parents i think what we're really
exploring now is around women who have
hepatitis c in pregnancy is
should we be
intervening in pregnancy so not just
screening to know but should we actually
consider treatment in pregnancy and if
we're not comfortable considering
treatment in pregnancy we definitely
need to treat in the postpartum period
as we understand it right now
most women are not treated in the
postpartum period before they become
pregnant again so we could treat
postpartum and then eliminate any risk
of ongoing
transmission in terms of that vertical
context
thank you
next question which hepatitis is most
dangerous a b or c
hmm
i feel like that's a loaded question
perhaps by an individual who already
knows the answer to that yeah i think it
really depends on the population that
you're looking at and of course the
there is some overlap in terms of the
populations affected by a b and c
um but when we think about half a so
this is often either in endemic
countries and it has a great impact
around young children
in terms of our settings in canada so
people are impacted by hepatitis a in
the context of experiencing homelessness
um and certainly they could have
fullmetal hepatitis and they could have
an extremely significant
disease but most people with hepatitis a
actually never know they have hep a and
so do not necessarily go on to liver
failure
you know b and c are obviously different
routes of transmission so in terms of
answering the question you know
from hep for hepatitis c people are
unlikely to have acute liver fail
leaving leading to cancer and with
hepatitis b
we might have a similar scenario around
um you know low risk of going on to
hepatocellular carcinoma whereas hepe
would be that acute significant viral
illness but i think the scary thing is
is that
most people with hepatitis b and c do
not know they are infected and do not
know they have symptoms and so with a
people might have an extremely bad
course of disease they could become
quite sick most will recover but for b
and c
if we don't screen people will go on to
have you know liver failure liver cancer
and that potential is really there and
we don't always know who's going to go
on to have significant liver disease and
so for me personally that's why i think
it's extremely scary
in terms of answering that question
all right thank you
um
next question
would it
would it be useful if the hcv antibody
rapid tests for screening and then
confirm the positives with hcv antigen
yeah i think it's an algorithm that make
could make sense
so um you know in an outreach setting um
where point of care antibody is ideal to
do that test um on site and then draw
labs for
uh core antigen i think that makes a ton
of sense but i think the thing to
consider is that the the cost of the
point of care test is actually quite
high so at least in our canadian market
it's about 30
and compared to core antigen which i
sort of mentioned in our canadian market
would be reimbursed at
15
that's half the cost so i think when you
think about the whole pathway you need
to think about which populations are you
testing
is there a high likelihood that they're
going to be antibody positive and if so
maybe we just skip
um that being said
someone knowing that they're antibody
positive
can at times be an engagement tool so
people know they're positive and they
get retested they might be re-engaged
into the care cascade and more likely to
get linked to care treated and cured
all right thank you
next question
is it possible for an individual to
contract a mixed hepatitis infection
yeah certainly so
in terms of viral hepatitis maybe i'll
just speak to viral hepatitis because of
course there's other types of hepatitis
um in terms of viral hepatitis we
actually want to be really proactive in
this arena and so for people that have
hepatitis c
we encourage providers to look for hep a
and hep b infection immunity um in the
context of hep b infection and for both
immunity
because we have a great tool to
vaccinate individuals so they don't have
hep a while having hep c
in terms of viral co-infection so b and
c together this is possible and we do
see it
it's not as common because the viruses
do compete for replication in the
hepatocyte um and certainly there is
also a predisposition where having one
viral hepatitis so c
might lead to less hat b just because of
that competition so it's possible to see
a true co-infection and it's certainly a
part of our work up for treatment to
make sure they don't have a co-infection
but it's not very common
all right thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
what about a combo hcv assay antibody
plus antigen like we have for hiv would
it be useful
yeah again it kind of goes to what i was
saying before i think it's useful in
certain settings so i think it could be
useful if um the cost is reasonable for
that setting and if it makes sense to do
the screening test at all so in the
context of hiv it's a little bit
different because of course an antibody
positivity is indicative of infection
and so even though we do this in our
fourth generation hiv assay so antibody
testing plus antigen testing we're
really looking for infection there in
the context of hep c it could have
utility for screening but if we already
know people are antibody positive which
i mean at least where i let where i am
in the world people are tested sometimes
five times for any body positivity um it
might not be that helpful so i think it
does really depend on the intention of
the test and this ability to mix and
match i just can't emphasize that enough
because it's not going to be a one size
fits all for this population
all right thank you thank you dr biandi
do you have any final comments for our
audience
i just wanted to again say thank you for
joining me today um in the context of
world hepatitis and really thinking
about elimination um you know this is
really grassroots work this is really
working within your community with
working within your network and then
getting that political advocacy and
engagement so you've taken the first
step by coming and attending here today
and please feel free to reach out to me
for any additional questions and follow
up
thank you again dr biandi for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor abbott diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone and
goodbye
you